bonjour à tous on a beaucoup parlé des
écrans pliables il ya quelques temps
avec effectivement le galaxy x qui vont
arriver aussi avec 1
trop soft surface qui pour arriver
surface phone complètement pliable mais
on n'a pas parlé encore axxon
[Musique]
je vous la fais un petit peu à l'envers
on veut entrer ben c'est pas du tout à
l'écran pire ce rallye des deux écrans
c'est un smartphone
je dirais d'un seul bloc que vous avez
comme ça et vous avez le deuxième écran
qu'à l'arrière
donc lorsque vous le tenez comme ça ça
vous fait une espèce d'énorme smartphone
quelque chose d'un monde superstock
super énorme mais lorsque vous voulez
l'ouvrir on pourra voir un plus grand
écran pour en profiter vous avez qu'à
l'ouvrir comme ça et ça voulait
directement le deuxième écran à côté il
ya un côté pratique
après effectivement on n'est pas sur des
écrans pigalle le fabricant ces êtres on
va très bien exact vraiment aller dans
cette niche des produits avec des plus
grandes surfaces de travail et qui
tiennent dans la poche c'est à dire à un
smartphone pas une fable est pas une
tablette l'entre-deux alors
effectivement à la techno on va très
bien ici qu'on a deux écrans renvoi qui
a un côté le côté un peu intelligent du
truc c'est leur idée centrale qui a
l'air vraiment solide on arrive en but
et ça vient on attendait pas il ya trois
bourgs ici mais sa femme qui bruce
dahlgren confiance lorsqu'on leur ferme
ça vient idéalement se positionner à
l'intérieur on voit qu'effectivement
vous avez ici
des petits prend ici ils savent bien
bien ce qu'il fait le produit est plutôt
bien pensé maintenant le côté négatif
c'est que vous allez donc pouvoir mettre
deux coques de protection sans se
produit parce que de toute façon si vous
le mettez vous pourrez jamais l'ouvrir
vous pourrez jamais rien en faire donc
est ce que c'est un produit qui est
fragile c'est un petit peu la question
que je peux me poser là dessus a
contrario vous avez effectivement pas
d'appareil photo à l'arrière parce qu'il
va fermer
ça ne sert strictement à rien par contre
vous avez les normes caméra à l'avant
qui a l'air vraiment vraiment costaud
vous avez deux écrans de 5,2 pouces full
hd en 1920 par 1080
c'est du verre gorilla donc qu'en terme
de qualité ça tient vraiment la route
vous avez ici d'une grosse caméra quand
vous lisez c'est une caméra 20
mégapixels
j'ai aucune info sur l'ouverture ni sur
vraiment la qualité et je vais essayer
de retrouver les devoirs
ça marche si je m'en sors avec ce
smartphone voici la caméra la qualité
pas mal alors effectivement ici chez
nous un endroit extrêmement éclairé donc
c'est vraiment trop peur mais d'un point
de vue qualité
[Musique]
la caméra a vraiment l'air de faire le
job alors voyez ici on voit mon joli gh5
et panasonic
mais bon regardant comme ça ça a l'air
pas mal on peut régler la luminosité
plus bas on a un mode beauty faille pour
rendre encore plus beau on peut jouer ou
la fédé ait fait un peu bizarre ça c'est
le mode bio qui failli
[Musique]
vous avez un mode vidéo social oui vous
pouvez poser de cette manière là pour
pouvoir poser regarder vos vidéos sur un
seul écran d'un côté grosse un sens
pourquoi pas c'est ça fait un peu gadget
mais c'est sympa près ce qu'il faut sur
ce produit c'est vraiment l'épaisseur
alors correspond les smartphones de plus
en plus petit celui là il est énorme
mais il est vraiment énorme marque on
pense que vous l'ouvrez en côte à côte
ça fait vraiment son petit effet c'est
un produit qui pèse quand même 230
grammes
mais c'est pas énorme mais c'est quand
même son poids ce qu'aucun autre
batterie on est une 3180 millions mes
erreurs et on a la recharge rapide mais
je vous lis j'ai la fiche à côté c'est
le qualcomm +2 csaj 3.0 en donnant qu'un
processeur qualcomm snapdragon armv8 il
tourne sous android 7.1 1.2 moga on a 4
gigas de ram et 64 giga de stockage pour
commenter jusqu'à 256 digue du bluetooth
4.2 de l'usb titre si vous avez une
prise jack qui se situe ici en haut de
l'appareil
vous avez ici votre emplacement pour la
seule haute avec les boutons volume le
bouton pour l'allumer dont je ne sais
pas quoi il sert côté son vous avez
dolby atmos
stéréo et pour la vidéo vous pouvez
filmer jusqu en 4k ce produit sera pas
pour monsieur tout le monde
il va vraiment aller vers des gens qui
veulent vraiment avoir un produit avec
un très très grand écran qu'on peut
plier mettre dans sa poche
en tout cas ce qu'on va vraiment se
produit c'est que c'est annonciateur de
cette gamme de produits dont vous parlez
pas comme par rapport au samsung galaxy
x c'est très très grand écran c'est
vraiment sur quoi on va on va se diriger
au côté de la version d'écran et indiqué
super intéressant vous pouvez choisir
sur les deux écrans sony met les grands
arbres de chapeauter soit mettre l'écran
à sur l'ensemble du produit leçons m un
côté à côté des sommets juste d'un seul
côté et l'autre fermé et vous avez
également un capteur d'empreintes
digitales
voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui dans ce produit cette traque
sonne m
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est ce
que ça peut vous intéresser est ce que
vous trouvez cette typologie de produits
intéressants
est-ce que ce côté d'écran qui se plie
s'avoue séduit vous marquez tout ça me
manque aussi vraiment intéressant parce
que même s'il se produit pas génial en
tout cas ça va dans le bon sens mark et
moi tout ça on en parle
je vous invite à mener cette jolie
pousse à vous abonner restez connectés
je vous embrasse et à très bientôt pour
nous un nouveau test high tech en direct
du cs à las vegas ciao
[Musique]